- The worst thing I could
think of is you spill it
and your kitchen looks
like a murder scene.
I'm gonna don gloves cause
we're working with blood.
Gets under your fingernails.
- It may seem
like an unlikely ingredient
in modern cuisine,
but blood is popping up on
menus across the country.
- It's no different than utilizing any
off cut of the animal.
All the greatest cuisines
in the world are definitely
sprung out of the need
to utilize everything.
This is corn masa.
We dehydrated it for the purpose of
re-hydrating it with
pig's blood.
- Why would you use blood
and not water?
- For us it's just
about the flavor.
- What's it taste like?
- When it's raw it's
actually not pleasant at all.
When you cook it, if you love
great chicken liver, if you
love great calves' liver
it's a better version of that.
- [Woman] Along with flavor
and re-hydration, blood
can also act as a thickener and color dye.
(exciting music)
- It's a very polarizing ingredient.
It's either: there's no way
in hell I'm ordering that or,
oh man, awesome.
- Should I try blood?
- Of course you should.
You should try everything.
You should try every exciting,
new confrontational culinary
thing that comes across your path.
It's still very much
unfortunately a taboo ingredient.
I find the best way to get
somebody to try something
is to craft it into a
small beautiful bite.